[Music]
new story depicts the life of two
teenage rivals embroiled in a gangland
war in South London but its creator rap
man says essentially it's a film about
love not violence there was no denying
the violence however which erupted on
Saturday it's a cinema complex in
Birmingham which was showing the film
involving around a hundred people six
teenagers were arrested several officers
were injured and two machetes and a
knife were recovered prompting chains
showcase and view to withdraw blue story
from all their outlets something one of
its actors says is incredibly
disappointing it's a thing of
worthlessness and when this decision
gets made it makes you fool like is it
that easy for them to just you know take
away our voice that's the issue that's
why people are outraged like that
because of the milestones or the hurdles
someone I wrap my heart to go through to
get to this point the film was a long
time in the making starting life as a
miniseries on YouTube
cultivating a huge following and
ensuring all involved are heavily
invested in its success have they seen
the film - like know how stupid that
decision was I mean that's that's all I
could put it that I know I'll be I'm a
bit by so that's all I can put it down -
it must be it must be racism it just
must be the film's not promoting gang
violence is about like the people it's
not really about like the primary is
that the people in the conditions and
how that means other people feeling that
kind of thing so I thought it's a bit
unfair in a statement
view cinema said the decision to
withdraw blue story is not as some have
alleged based on biased assumptions or
concern about the content of the film
itself during the first 24 hours over 25
significant incidents were reported and
escalated to senior management in 16
separate cinemas this is the biggest
number we have ever seen for any film in
such a short timeframe but critics say
this is not a good enough reason to ban
it with the purge anarchy there were
incidents with the Dark Knight Rises
back in 2012 but those films they went
to the banned from a lot of sort of
similar cinema sites and you know blue
story is a film which needs the support
from some of our chains like you
showcase have now reversed their
decision and will be showing blue story
and move those linked with the movie
hope view will now follow music ah sir
Sky News and they ain't trying to
justify but imma show you what these
young BAE the factored form